Musik 1, 2, 3, sind wir schon drauf? Ja, ho rein, wir sind drauf. Mein Name ist Stefan Michael Tietze, ich bin Flo und den Will und wir haben heute eine Podcast-Folge speziell mit deinem Gast. Hallo, ich begrüsse dich ganz herzlich, Tine Krupke. Tine Krupke, Künstlername Tine Adams, so kennt ihr wie sie wahrscheinlich und habt sie wahrscheinlich dadurch gefunden, Erstmal sind ihr habt sie immer wieder allmorgendlich aufgestanden, seid erstmal in Google in die Tassen gehauen, Tina Adams, was treibt sie heute wieder, was ist los? Welchen Liedstrich zieht sie sich heute? Hat sie ein neues YouTube-Tutorial hochgeladen, was macht sie so? Und wir haben... Autorin, Komedienne, Schauspielerin, Musicalsängerin, One Day More, Another Day, Another Destiny, welches Musical? Also du bist absolut le miserable. Le miserable.
Ja, bei dir ist es immer le miserable, egal was du singst.
Man ist in einem anderen Raum und hört dich sagen, was für ein Musical und es ist immer le miserable.
Starlight Express.
Cats auf jeden Fall, das ist recht einfach.
Du bist Ghostwriterin.
Darf man nicht sagen?
Naja, man weiss nicht.
Nee, darf man nicht sagen, aber kann man sagen, ja.
Finde ich aber interessant, weil potenziell könnte ja einfach jeder behaupten, er ist Ghostwriter für Tolkien, für Harry Potter, weil man darf ja nicht sagen, für wen du arbeitest. Aber ich habe ja nicht so eine Urkunde oder so einen Stirnbind, was man die ganze Zeit tragen muss, um offensichtlich zu zeigen, man ist gerade Ghostwriter. Meine Investigativfrage an dich lautet, für wen denn? Ja, das ist die Frage, ne? Also wenn ich das jetzt sagen würde, dann wären, glaube ich, manche Leute ziemlich sauer oder ich müsste eine Konventionale Strafe leisten, aber wenn man so einen Schminktutorialsender hat, dann kann man sich das ja auch leisten, so eine Konventionale Strafe zu zahlen. Aber was würde es passieren, wenn du sagen würdest, hier, Paul Panzer, für den habe ich schon mal ein Geld geschrieben, wie viel müsstest du dann zahlen, wie viel Geld? Das kann ich dir jetzt gar nicht sagen weil so für so grosse wirklich Comedians habe ich jetzt noch nicht geschrieben, das muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Das ist vertragsabhängig. Also manche Leute kommen auf mich zu und sagen, ey, du hast ein bisschen eine Schraube locker, mir fehlt vielleicht nach so vielen Jahren irgendwie, wo ich auch selber mein Programm geschrieben habe oder wo ich Autorin habe, irgendwie die Ideen. Kannst du dazukommen, kannst du was schreiben, hast du einen Titel für mein Programm und dann läuft das. Eigentlich ist es ganz oft ein Freundschaftsdienst, weil ich halt aus der Comedy-Szene komme, durch RTL Samsternacht zum Beispiel oder … Baue ich fort? Baue ich einfach fort. Copyright, ist alles Copyright. Nicht so gut, 90 Sekunden davon anspülen. Das stimmt auch nicht. Wunderschön, also ich glaube auch, das wird deine Bestimmung sein, irgendwann den Rusty in Bochum zu spielen. Ja, Rusty oder tatsächlich doch Elektra. Oder ja. Oder dieses grosse Gebiss ganz am Anfang, das würde ich gerne spielen. Ja, das ist ja wieder ein anderes Musiker, ne? Ne, das ist Rocky Horror Picture Show. Ja, wir waren ja schon bei Starlight Express, du Scheissidiot. Mach doch einmal mit, Rusty.
Aber was ich heute, wir haben ja vorhin schon mit dir gesprochen, was ich gehört habe und was ich häufiger gehört habe, ist, dass du früher Musical gespielt hast, jetzt aber komplett damit abgeschlossen hast.
Und da hatten wir schon ein paar Leute da, die gesagt haben, ich habe früher Musical gemacht, aber habe jetzt da gar keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Absolut.
Das hilft irgendwann.
Warum ist das denn, warum wollen da so viele Leute weg, warum haben da so viele Leute keinen Bock mehr auf Musical?
Na, Bock habe ich schon. Also das ist immer noch eine grosse Leidenschaft von mir, aber man darf sich da auch nichts vormachen, wirklich in diese grossen Produktionen reinzukommen und sich da zu halten. Das ist einfach schon schwierig. Und wenn du eigentlich einen Vertrag hast, du hast immer einen Vertrag für ein Jahr, was im Künstler-Business eigentlich schon viel ist, musst du dich aber eigentlich schon am Anfang darum kümmern, dass du eine neue Rolle hast. Das heisst du unterschreibst jetzt bei Starlight Express als Beispiel und musst aber dann schon gucken, dass du für das nächste Jahr wieder neue, neue Show hast. Und dann rennst du zur Audition und dann hast du wirklich mehrere Runden, da sitzen zum Schluss irgendwie zehn Leute, die sehen aus wie du. Was albern ist, weil im Endeffekt kriegst du eine Perücke. Also du musst halt auch solche Sachen abstimmen, das ist total bekloppt. Was echt interessant ist bei bei Musicals, da hast du oft einfach die gleiche, die Rollen sind oft sehr ähnlich. Also du hast immer so einen schrägen Vogel, ob es bei Sazu ist oder Caboose bei Star Express. Das war ein gutes Wortspiel, ein schräger Vogel, Sazu, ne? Ja, ja, Sazu. Der auch noch ein Vogel ist. Und dann auch noch, du hast dann noch, ich weiss nicht, bei Les Miserables, das ist der seltsame Besitzer dieser Bar oder so, genau genau. Du hast immer diesen einen schrägen Vogel, dann hast du diesen weisen Mann, immer ob es jetzt der Star-Fan-Style-Express der Papa ist oder Jean-Van-Jean oder Obi-Wan Kenobi. Krass wie ihr euch ausgeht, das macht ja voll Angst. Du hast immer so einen weisen Mann, du hast immer die oft männliche Hauptperson. Die geschundene, leidende Frau natürlich. Leidende Frau, immer, genau. Ich glaube, deswegen ist es auch relativ einfacher, welche Rolle man sich danach in diesem Jahr bewirbt, wahrscheinlich einfach. Weil du oft schon im Kopf warst, okay, ich bin das Pendant zu Rusty oder whatever. Ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Also ich glaube nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie für irgendeine lichterfüllte Rolle irgendwie... Ein Mensch versteht das, Chef. Das sind halt vielleicht gute Gags in irgendeinem Universum, aber nicht im Podcast-Ufo. In einer Gay-Community, glaube ich, kommt das mega an. Die ganze Saison, die gerade beim Lidl oder beim Obi stehen an der Tegel, einfach, Pearl, ha, Pearl hat er gesagt, Alter, was für ein mega-Gag, mehr aber auch nicht, ha, ha, ha, ha. Pearl H war das Musical vielleicht, vielleicht hast du gerade eine neue Idee gewonnen. Ja, Pearl H war das Musical. Ja, das ist nicht schlecht. Wow,, da sehe ich auch mit vielen Asiaten, die alle draufgegen. Ich sehe die Pauken kommen auch. Die ersten Kamikaze-Sängerdeutschen. Miauuum! Was würdest du gerne mal als Musical sehen? Sehen? Sehen oder Hören? Sehen oder Hören? Das ist jetzt keine Limitierung. Fühlen vielleicht. Also Sehen und Hören. Welches ich gerne sehen würde, eigentlich die, die ich schon sehen wollte, habe ich schon gesehen.
Was als Musical? Also würdest du jetzt sagen, die Abwrackprämie, das Musical oder so? The Dawes, also wirklich Türen einfach, die singen. Absolut, also ich halte ja immer noch an meiner Idee fest, wirklich, da haben wir ja gerade noch kurz drüber geschnackt, würdest es cool finden, wirklich einen, ein, entweder einen Modern Talk in das Musical
zu machen, wo alle, ähm, Atlantis is calling, wer kennt das nicht, ne? Aber lass mal kurz, lass mal kurz, ähm, also bei, bei Queen war es ja auch so, We Will Rock You ist eine sehr seltsame Geschichte, weil ja erst die Songs da waren, die in keiner Reihenfolge waren, in keiner sinnvollen Zusammenhaltigkeit. Und dann hat man halt irgendwie so eine Geschichte darum gestrickt, die ja total Gaga ist, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und deswegen, was wäre denn bei Modern Talking die Geschichte? Ja, das ist die Frage. Natürlich die Nora-Kette, Nora ist natürlich eine ganz grosse Rolle. Aber gibt es einen Nora-Song? Ja, das muss man dann sehen. Vielleicht ist Nora Cherry Cherry Lady, die zusammen mit Brother Louie auf dem Weg geht. Ja, vielleicht ist das auch einfach nur ein Bruder, der in Sa-Louie wohnt, so dass man sagt, das ist mein Brother Louie. Was sind noch bekannte Modern Talking Songs? Atlantis is Calling, SOS for Love, wer kennt das nicht? So, da hört es bei euch auf, Jungs. Ich kenne es auch nicht so, ich überlege ein Nora-Wortspiel seit zwei Minuten, aber es gefällt nichts an. Zwei, wir müssen auch ein Modern Talking-Wortspiel, keine Chance allein. Also ihr könnt hier alle Musical-Playlists von hoch runter singen, aber bei Modern Talking ist dann eure Ekelgrenze erreichbar. Das sagst du jetzt so, ich kenne vielleicht viele Musicals in meinem Leben gesehen und da habe ich mir die Rollen gemerkt. Stefan ist ein Musicalblender, der kann zwei Sachen und dann denkt man so, wow, cool, der ist Musical-Fan, aber wenn man wirklich so merkt, äh, Phantom der Oper im dritten Akt, noch mal genau hat da den Mezzosopran, dann schwächelt er. Da kommt nichts mehr dahinter. Ich habe Annie Get Your Gun mitgesungen, kennt aber auch niemand, kann ich nicht mit angeben, und Kiss-Met, was auch niemand kennt. Kiss-Met? Ja, so ein, naja, das wäre ja geil. Das ist halt die Einbahnstrasse Musical-Gags. Einbahnstrasse Musical, ja, absolut. Warum haben die Leute keinen Bock mehr, warum ist Musical so ein langweiliges Thema, dass die Leute sagen, bitte, bitte hört auf damit?
Ja, pff, du, also langweilig, also das kann ich jetzt nicht unterschreiben, ne, dass es langweilig ist nicht, aber es ist halt, wenn du, wenn du das als, natürlich musst du da irgendwie, also viele Männer kotzen ja ab, wenn die sagen, Mensch, die Freundin hat jetzt ein Wochenende gebucht, Musicaltrip, ich glaube, da gibt es die wenigsten...
Musicaltrip, was heißt das, man schaut das ganze Wochenende immer ein Musical an oder was? Nee. Das klingt nach dem besten fucking Wochenende ever. Ja, oder? Ja, könnte man eigentlich mal ein Vorbilder. Einen Abend König der Löwen darf ein Wochenende in Hamburg verbringen, das ist, glaub ich. Ach so. Hast du das denn schon mal gesehen, König der Löwen? Mhm. Hast du da was verstanden? Mhm. Ja? Warum nicht? Ich verstehe den Text da immer ganz schlecht. Echt nicht? Das finde ich immer so bei englischsprachigen ... Na, Sigonia, Babagiti Baba, Sabatu, Gonia Baba. Ja, passt mal. Heißt übersetzt? Ja, scheiss, weissen Arschlöcher macht Afrika kaputt mit einem Scheissgeld, ihr verdammten Drecksvisagen, oh, jetzt muss ich auf einer Story weitermachen. Wir haben damals gesagt, wir wollen kein Geld, wir schliessen uns diesen Trend nicht an. Und jetzt haben wir jetzt davon Scheiße. Aber ich kann ganz gut singen, bin schwarz, deswegen singe ich jetzt hier eine Figur, die sehr, sehr eindimensional gezeichnet ist. Also so eine Tourette-Rolle. Ja, ich glaube, sowas ist das. Deswegen auch direkt NAAA! Das fängt ja so an, das Musical. Ja, aber es ist doch ein Tramjob, wenn du die Rolle als Beispiel hast, dann kommst du immer gechillt nach Hause. Wenn du da deine ganzen Aggressionen in einer Phantasiesprache... Wer das für dich? Rafiki? Absolut. Ich meine mit meinem Tang. Es sind irgendwann auch einfach nur noch Begriffe, nur noch Worte. Es sind irgendwann einfach nur noch Impro. Kein Name. Ich denke mir, seit zehn Minuten denke ich mir Dinge aus. Waffolev, kann ich auch sagen einfach. Aber was treibt dich sonst um? Wir sind ja? Also wir sind ja auch hier gerade, weil du auch Comedy magst, ne? Was treibt dich da um? Was sind die Gags, die du interessant findest, die Pointen, auf denen du auf der Suche bist? Wo nimmst du Inspiration her? Also was ist deine Comedy-Muse? Wow, okay. Also, wo ich ein grosser Freund von bin, sind echt Leute, die gut mit der Sprache umgehen können, richtig schlechte Wortspiele. Was für dich ein richtig schlechtes, damit meinst du gut, das ist die Ironie. Was meinst du da zum Beispiel? Zum Beispiel, okay das ist jetzt sehr flach, aber wie nennt man einen Käse, der nicht erwachsen werden will? Ein Teenager vielleicht? Ein Käse. Ja, ja, ich dachte Teenager mit irgendeiner Käsesorte vielleicht, der nicht erwachsen
werden will.
Warte mal, wer will nicht erwachsen werden?
Kind, Kinder?
Emmentaler.
Gauder.
Ich brauche jetzt eine Antwort.
Er sagt Gauder, ich sage Emmentaler.
Was ist die Antwort?
Fetapan.
Ah, ja, okay.
Ach so was.
Ja.
Was ist eine ... Ich kann mir sowas auch nicht merken.
Vielen Dank. Sada Gauda ist ja eventuell da was die Antwort. Fetapan. Ah, ja okay. Feta, ach sowas. Ja. Was ist eine, ne, ich kann mir sowas auch nicht merken, Gürkin war jedenfalls die Pointe. Denkt euch da jetzt, denkt euch jetzt eure. Classic L-Form, da ist mit der Pointe anfangen und dann die Leute raten lassen, dass es das gleiche wie Was ist Weiss und statt beim Essen eine Lawine und sowas, das ist ja auch lustig. Ja. Wenn sie das lustig findet, ist das okay, lass sie mal, das ist in Ordnung. Jeder hat das Recht, lustig zu finden, was sie möchte. Also innerlich zerreißt es mich auch gerade, ich könnte mich jetzt lohlend über den Boden rollen. Sie rollt auch gerade über den Boden, aber sie kann das nachsprachlich, merkt mir das nicht an. Aber sie kann dabei sehr gut weiterreden, ganz normal. Es ist halt, wenn man eine Musical-Ausbildung hat, ne, dann kann man sowas. Ja, klar, muss man eigentlich machen. Tell me more, tell me more, did she blow up a fight, shoo more, show me more, the producers, du bist ein Fan? Ich hab's gesehen, ja, fand's sehr cool. In New York? And now it's springtime for Hitler and Germany. Look at springtime, winter for Poland. Ich bin ziemlich überraschend. Selbst wenn du zu einer Musical-Odition gehst, du hörst die Leute nicht so viel singen, wie ihr es tut und das begrüsse ich sehr. Wir haben dich noch gar nicht singen gehört. Wir singen, um nicht weinen zu müssen. Sing mal ruhig, sing mal was von Adele. Aber sing mal so die ersten Sachen, was sie als Kind gesungen hat, als Adele. Also ich muss, ich kann euch jetzt was, das habe ich noch nie irgendwo öffentlich, ausser vier Wendler erzählt, wo ich meinen ersten Gesangsauftritt hatte. Gibt es zwei peinliche Fotos noch, die meine Eltern gemacht haben. Ich glaube, wenn ich das sage, wir werden uns nie wiedersehen. Ich hatte meinen ersten Gesangsauftritt mit Marianne und Michael. Oh, Marianne, was? Geil. Knall als Anekdote incoming. Absolut, absolut. Es gibt da auch noch Fotos von, also wirklich zwei, wie ich da mit meinem blauen Kleid mit rosa, Monden und Sternen in der Duisburger Rhein-Ruhr-Halle war das, glaube ich, stand und mit denen ein Lied gesungen habe und danach total, wahrscheinlich ist das der Grund, warum ich fast nur noch schwarz trage, also Marianne Mariano Michel, glaube ich, das war mir zu viel Fröhlichkeit und zu viel gute Laune. Absolut, absolut. Ja, aber das war so, wo ich gedacht habe, okay, und dann... Moment, du bist ja dann fertig quasi jetzt. Was ist da passiert? Ich will den Auftritt, erzähl dir nach. Was ist da passiert? Ja, das weiß ich nicht mehr so genau. Wie alt war ich da? Gib uns einen kurzen Einblick, was war der Auftritt? Da war ich sechs Jahre, ich kann euch nichts mehr Fotos sagen. Was hast du denn gesungen?
Das Lied hieß, kannst du eigentlich, kannst du das googeln?
Man kann alles googeln, man kann zumindest versuchen.
Wenn die Gema ganz kurz wegschauen kann, kann ich das auch googeln.
So textsicher bin ich nicht mehr, ist irgendwas mit Land, gib mal ein Marianne und Michael, ich glaube Unser Land hieß das.
Deutschland, so, Deutschland. Warte mal, You poor, Michael, Un, Deutschland.
Warte mal, you poor, Michael, unser Land.
Unser Land.
Ach ja doch, das gibt's doch.
Das hast du gesungen, jetzt gib mal rein.
Hau mal ab, die Disco kannst du es auch machen?
Das Intro war auf jeden Fall sehr erschreckend schon.
Ich lasse mir das Mikrofon.
Ja, das war das.
Achtung, jetzt kommt der Refrain. Jetzt singen wir mit. Ja, du ... Toll, das hast du gesungen. Ach, vor allem die Message ist ja auch toll. Und so aktuell wie nie. Ja, ich habe es bis heute auch nicht verstanden. Vielleicht wäre das mal irgendwie ... Mein Land ist dein Land. Ja. Also auch der Flüchtlinge, die jetzt zu uns stoßen. Absolut. Also eigentlich wäre das jetzt klug gewesen, das rauszubringen von den Land. Wie stehst du zu der ganzen Flüchtlingsthematik? Ja … Was soll der Scheiss, ne? Scheiss Flüchtlinge, was wollen die alle hier? Ja, ist wie es ist, ne? Also Hashtag, Refuge is welcome, ne? Ja, gut. Ja, gut. Warum wird eigentlich mit so vielen Hashtags, warum reden Leute in Hashtags, das frage ich mich in letzter Zeit auch. Hast du dich verletzt? Das ist, glaube ich, das ist auch so eine ganz, ah, der grösste Trottel der Fucking-Welt, ey. Das ist mir ja immer mein Mikrofon gegen die Wange gehauen, zum Erleid. Das passiert mir aber auch in jeder Folge mehrere Male, aber mittlerweile lasse ich es einfach unkommentiert. Ist so ein Zwang von dir, oder? Das tut echt weh, er hängt eine Wangenknoche, okay, sorry, ja. Ist ein ein Zwang von dir. Warum Leute in Hashtags reden, es macht absolut keinen Sinn, es ist dazu da, um im Internet Themen zu finden und die Leute zusammen über ein Thema schreiben, was man dann besser finden kann, so Archivfunktionen eigentlich. Wenn Leute so reden, macht es gar keinen Sinn. Ja, aber kennt ihr auch so Leute, die im Handy auch Hashtags zeigen? Ja. Hashtags und wenn sie dann Fotos posten, gibt's ja auch Foodies und nicht nur Selfies, sondern auch dann fotografiert's dann seine … Fruities heißen die. Fruities. Fruit Loops. Absolut. Meinst du, glaub ich. Douglas? So Fruities kenn ich jetzt nicht, aber was ist Fruities, dann fotografiert man einen Apfel. Ja, sowas in der Richtung. Oder aber auch eine Banane. Mhm. Oder eine Weintraube. Wenn es ganz verrückt wird, einen ganzen Obstkorb, oder? Obstkorb. Ähm. Jetzt bin ich darauf gekommen. Eine Erdbeere. Okay. Nee, ist eine Nuss eigentlich. Was fotografiert ihr so? Birne. Ich fotografiere viel in meiner Wohnung, weil es mir immer unangenehm, ich habe mir eine Kamera gekauft, aber es ist mir immer unangenehm, die auch mitzunehmen nach draußen, weil dann sehe ich immer aus wie so ein Tourist, aber ich bin ja hier kein Tourist in Köln, das ist mir immer zu lächerlich. Und dann bleibe ich meistens in der Wohnung und fotografiere dann da Dinge, aber schöne Fotos. Zum Beispiel? Mein Herd oder meinen Kühlschrank habe ich hier oft auch innen drin fotografiert. Du hast mir nie ein Foto von deinem Herd gezeigt, das würde mich mal interessieren. Ich habe mehrere Alben voller Bilder von meinem Herd, ich kann dir die alle mal schicken. 80 MB aber. Also ich habe eine Festplatte, alleine für Herdfotos. You're my Herd, you're my soul? Ja. You're my heart, you're my fucking soul, die grosse Schlussballade. Wird achtmal gesungen und dann sind wir fertig damit mit dem scheiß Musical. Geh mal raus! Dann werden die Leute rausgeschmissen, ey. Wir singen den Song, bis die Halle leer ist, Leute. Ja, das Merchandise würde dafür wahrscheinlich gut funktionieren. Können wir noch einen Herd mit einbauen? Herd einbauen, fertig, ey. Knall den das Musikgelaufen, Tisch, ey. Kein Problem, wir füllen die Scheiss-Sendung schon irgendwie, kein Problem, wir singen, bis die Deppen aufhören zu klatschen, ist mir doch egal, machen irgendwas, einfach, passt schon. Jo, wir spielen laut. Laut, wo kam denn auch der Hamburger Dialektplosier? Laut das nicht machen. Habe es so Hamburger, Dinger. Ja sicher, ein bisschen schon. Ja sicher, komm ich das bewusst.
Ja klar, kein Ding doch.
Ja, kannst du ja auch aus Nordisch reden, du, das ist ja kein Problem.
Wo kommst du her, gebürtlich?
Ich komme gebürtlich aus dem Rheinland.
Du musst dir vielleicht eine bessere Sache ausdenken. Springtime for Hitler and Germany. Springtime, springtime, spring Genau, morgen früh, so Gott will, ja, ja, ja. Also da hätte ich als Kind schon mega Druck einzuschlafen, da hätte ich schon Angst.
Ja, ja. So man denkt auch, okay, vielleicht schlafe ich am besten jetzt nicht, weil wenn Gott halt den Tag hat ...
Ich ziehe das durch, trinke Red Bull und bleib wach.
... habe ich ein Problem, ja.
Ja, absolut.
Gut, alles klar.
Alles klar, alles gesagt.
Dann vielen Dank, dass du da warst, mach gut, wir sind UFO, wir heben jetzt nochmal ab am Ende, deswegen wir heben jetzt ab.
Rempebembembembembembem, heute wird Getriebeschaden, Rempebembembembembembem. Mach das nicht, ey, die Zuschauer machen es fertig, wennben jetzt ab. Bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm, bäm,